good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Friday a CBR a great gorgeous
stunning beautiful and smart
day exactly happy Friday everyone we did
it we made it not only to the end of the
week but to the weekend of the Year oh
my God it's the week it's the party of
the month not the party of the Year
superbow weekend Jackson turd reunited
weekend I that's so true it's like I
can't even be excited about what I'm
going through like I know you're going
through a lot personally today and like
today was supposed to be such an
exciting day like the last toast before
I go and see Jacks I was talking
yesterday so much on the horizon and
then in just a minute your life can
change so why don't you share with
everyone kind of like what you're going
through ah and you know what I didn't
even want to talk about it cuz I feel
like it reflects poorly on me it does it
does I didn't know if you were going to
talk about it honestly oh my God so
should I not no you have to now and and
now we've hyped it up so when you
actually say it people be like oh that's
it
okay and I just feel like it's not
representative of who I am or the way I
choose to live my life by the way we
just need to clip this as a clickbait
where we're like Claudia needs to share
it reflects poorly on me okay and be
super click ba yeah I like that okay so
let me start again okay I don't feel
like what I'm about to share is really
representative of who I am or like my
family's values or how we choose to live
our life and it's just kind of something
that happened to me and I was hesitant
to share it because people going to have
judgments you know they're going to hear
what I have to say and be like oh you're
that type of like person and I just want
to clear the air before I say what it is
is that like this happened to me I did
not attract this this sort of chaos I
certainly did not seek it out so having
said that last night I was home alone
Ben was at the Nick game with Craig
Conover and I subtle Flex yeah yeah yeah
I mean I'm still G to be me Jackie you
know yeah they can't take that away from
you and I'm laying in bed eating taco
meat and watching TV and I like you know
I'm very like hyper paranoid like you
know I'm very sensitive to like movement
and light like I always think there's a
you're aware of your surroundings I
always think there's like a murderer and
like I saw something move in the corner
of my eye which happens to me all the
time and I just like you know followed
my line of sight and I saw a
mouse there was domestic terrorist in my
home a mouse a brown
one and I
froze
freeze I think I I don't even remember
it's like I kind of blacked out I got up
on the bed and like was screaming I
can't even imagine screaming and in that
moment Lauren Elizabeth decides to
FaceTime me I'm like not now I
just froze he disappeared under my
radiator went on with his day
I ran downstairs like literally naked I
like wasn't wearing pants I I couldn't
go into the closet there could have been
another mouse in there an army of
mice and I you
know you fled the premises of course I
fled the premises my building was
amazing exterminator is there right now
was there a therapist on staff no no
therapist I needed seriously a gun
I did not sleep a wink I I did not go
back into my apartment until Ben got
home of course I was up all night
literally having night sweats I was in
like a full fit of sweats I was so
paranoid about the blanket touching the
floor cuz then that would give the mouse
like something to climb up on to and and
literally just climb into M just climb
into my mouth at that point you know
like
I like nobody likes rodents I and
everybody has like an aversion to them
but my my level is is is 100 out of 10
this is the worst possible thing that
could have happened to me especially
because like yesterday uh and it it's so
funny how like God works you know I
posted yesterday on patreon our uh my
book club Vlog and they're loving it
people are obsessed with my Vlog if you
want to see my book club w y y sneak
peeks in my apartment and I was reading
through the comments and somebody was
just like left such a sweet comment and
I was like kind of I think I was
literally reading it as I saw the mouse
it was like Claudia like you look so
happy in your new home I'm so happy for
you you've done such a great job you
look so at peace and I was like I am at
peace Mouse enter
mouse and it was not Mickey Mouse no and
I happen to have like the sighting of
the mouse which I know he's not there
anymore he like went on with his day
into another part of my house but like
the particular area where I found him
like it's an area I spend a lot of time
and it's right next to my vanity where I
podcast from home where I obviously do
my makeup do my hair like I spent a lot
of time there every day it felt personal
for sure yeah but you know the
Exterminator who is fabulous fabulous
Ralph I love this guy who came to this
morning so quick this was by the way 8
o'clock last night you know you can't
it's very impressive to get you know 8
8:00 Mouse sighting 10 o00 exterminator
that's 14 hours that's pretty good and
he was like you know I do this building
um and I was looking through my
paperwork and he's like you've never
been on my list I'm like well I just
moved in here he's like oh so I guess
the previous tenants didn't have an
exterminator and it's like it's free
with the building I'm like what the
are you doing maybe they like a little
mouse in their day so he's giving my
apartment the full workup I said I don't
have any you know babies around I don't
have any pets around I want it allclear
fumigate the out of this place chob
Chernobyl there should be a package plan
at the Exterminator yeah Chernobyl yeah
no and I just want to say like I'm all
about clean living like I'm very much
getting on that page with you one thing
that I will personally never allow
cleanliness I don't want a clean
exterminator I don't want an organic
exterminator I want a
radioactive
exterminator yeah especially when it's
m oh well that's the other thing it's
like you know living in New York you're
expected to deal with certain things and
unfortunately one of the more common
things is like water bugs roaches
cockroaches and in my time I have seen
roaches in my building in my apartment
they're to me they're more manageable
yeah they are it's it's a shock and it's
a horror it's shocking yeah and it's
just a part of people are going to be
like wow you guys are being so
nonchalant about it it really it's just
a part of the daily fabric of living in
New York like it is no but it's a shock
and a horror that we we can
manage 1,000% mouse mouse a mouse has
four legs a mouse is like Theo like
mous a mouse can be domes ticated like
it's insane yeah no that is a different
sort of
threat a different sort of threat but
with everything we have to be grateful
that it wasn't an
R yeah it was very
small and I just feel like that lady was
lying when she said the rats don't run
this town we do no like I experienced
firstand last night going to move out
give up her apartment squatter's rights
to the m jaie move out I'm burning the
building to the ground I like I'm going
to pull the fire alarm and get everybody
out because I I'm so upset like it's a
perfect time for you to be leaving the
state oh well let me just say how
absolutely thrilled I am that he's
fumigating the out of my apartment
I want traps everywhere and I leave
tomorrow for 3 weeks I'm not checking
the traps I'm going to have to have the
Exterminator come back hopefully while
I'm gone yeah I have the utmost
confidence in Ralph he was like giving
me really good
vibes yeah it's just It's upsetting that
this had to happen to me and of course
like how this now reflects upon me
people are like well you're disgusting
g- Leaf crumbs please oh my God have you
met me I'm the sweeper I've the cleanest
apartment this side of the East River
like please but it reflects poorly on me
now people are like oh that's the mouse
girl that's the mouse
girl right like writer girl no mousy
girl
yikes and I had to sleep with the sound
machine on so loud cuz if if I hear the
like oh I will seriously jump off my
balcony yeah for real for real but one
more sleep until you're coming here so
and and when was the last time your home
has been exterminated oh the pest guy
was here yesterday good we're super on
top of pest because there's a lot of
threats in Florida and it's different
sorts I mean there was that one night I
saw two palmals in my house and I didn't
know yet that Palm medals were different
from cockroaches still not great but not
a roach and we fled in the middle of the
night T's house did you sleep there yeah
that's funny yeah cuz I saw how nice two
in one night like I'm sorry that's
that's too too many uh and then also you
know there's you get like geckos in the
house and stuff like that but that's
just like there's really no way around
things like that yeah I don't know a
gecko to me is better than a mouse
geckos feel like clean no I see them I
don't want to say all the time but it
happens and I and I call Zach and then I
move on with my day I don't let it get
me down gecko can't get me down yeah and
like geckos and I know they say this
about all animals they're like you know
the pests are more afraid of you than
you are of it well the pest is obviously
not meant me because nobody's more
afraid of anything than I am of this
Pest and I feel like geckos like
actually are really afraid of you like
they're so like freaked yeah they don't
even move they're like how did I get
here how do I get out no you're like is
this gecko dead or just Frozen classic
gecko classic gecko so yes I of course I
have my own struggles and you also do
you do have snakes oh yeah I've heard St
I'm say you have a snake no but I've
heard from Neighbors snake snake
sightings that's that's worse than a
mouse I mean if I saw a snake in my
house like what would you do move yeah
they found us we're not safe oh I do
have like an update on 5K gate that I
actually forgot to tell you okay so um
while Bert yes never you know responded
to me with like a formal cordial
invitation his team has been in touch
with my team I just spoke to them
yesterday they're like listen we're
we're in touch with team team bird there
is a 5K great you know what we could
also do is listen to their show and find
out about these things I'm glad you
brought that up because obviously it
would clear up a lot of confusion if we
just like did the work um but one I'm
not one for doing work especially after
what I've just been through with the
mouse and two like it's so much more fun
to keep guessing 100% like please and
it's like are they listening to the
toast if not I don't know that you know
it's very tip for Tat around here we are
still Petty Queens no and like this is a
place of business
yeah but I guess like if we're really
hard up for wanting to know 5K or no 5K
should we start training we could just
listen to their show because people are
saying like no guys there is a 5K like
Lou CK is coming Joe Rogan's coming so
scary you know it's happening and Louis
C K's coming is Louis C K's penis coming
you know it because I want the full I
want the full experience like I I want
All I Want It All I want it I want it I
want it the fame and the fortune I want
it I want it all Fame and Fortune headed
your way yeah also I don't know if you
saw Joe Rogan is officially back on the
charts I saw he let's check our standing
we and I just want to say I feel like we
really did make the most of being number
two we we should be oh he's top show
okay what's going on in episodes they're
not up yet the episodes haven't episoded
yet okay so Joe is the top comedy show
we are number four that's okay he we're
number four when he's when he's number
one yeah I'm looking at it right now not
bad we we should be so proud dirty no we
should honestly like I and I do feel
good about the fact that like we knew he
was going to come back at some point we
really enjoyed his time off and I feel
like we made the most of it we made so
much content about it we talked about it
all the time like we did what we could
with what we had and now he's back rise
like and I feel like it's like bring it
on you have to be beat the best in order
to be the best it's so true it wasn't
even real no it wasn't but the
screenshots were nice and we'll always
have the screenshots yeah and the
screenshots like don't provide context
which is good yeah
totally so we've got a great show it's
Friday so we're just going to ease y'all
into the weekend we also have our very
famous Friday segment Queenie and weenie
of the week which will be awarded at the
end of the show so stay tuned for that
stay tuned for that without further Ado
let's into the fast five stories that
you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by Macy's because
Valentine's Day is next week and you can
use Macy's gift finder to find the
perfect gifts for everyone special in
your life and of course don't forget for
yourself as well plus you're getting 25%
up to 40% off underwear and lingerie
from Calvin Klein Gap and more top
brands some exclusions do apply and if
you need inspiration for gifts check out
their great ideas at macy's.com gift
I have to say Macy's is really a great
place for uh Valentine's Day shopping
you can get literally anything at Macy's
it's one of those department stores
that's just different like from home to
lingerie to clothing to men to women to
Beauty to fragrance like every time I
step into Macy's or on the website like
I'm really just reminded of how vast
their inventory is so you can get
creative of course like fragrances
lingerie those are always like good
Valentine's Day gifts but even if you're
just shopping for yourself also with the
big game coming up get ready at Macy's
from Team jerseys to serveware plus food
and snacks for every party you're
hosting attending hosting or attending
check it all out at macy's.com and if
you really have a hard time finding
someone a gift it's always good to get
them a gift card and I feel like a gift
card to Macy's like you they can
literally get a couch like they can get
anything so Macy's gift card gives this
Valentine's gift of Endless
Possibilities from 100% Kashmir sweaters
to soft Intimates and of course cozy
pajamas go to macy's.com giftcards for
the perfect gift for anyone today's
episode is also brought to you by honey
love it's the month of love and there's
nothing we love more than comfortable
shapewear support for today's episode
comes from honey love the company that
has revolutionalized compression
technology so you no longer have to feel
like you're suffocating while wearing
effective shapewear you will immediately
feel and see the difference plus their
shapewear features lingerie inspired
design details that you'll want to show
off for a limited time you can get honey
love on sale for 20% off your entire
order when you use the link honey
love.com toast so shapewear is honey
Love's bestselling product the superow
short is the go-to it's targeted
compression technology distinguishes
between areas that you want support and
areas that you need less compression
making it much more comfortable also
struggling to take off a piece of
shapewear we've all been there in the
bathroom literally I have thrown out
shapewear because I haven't been able to
get it back on at a wedding it doesn't
stop there honey love has more than just
sculptware they have incredibly
comfortable
bras tanks and leggings for everyday
support it is just as easy to put it on
as it is to take it off so treat
yourself to the best bras in shape we
the market and save 20% off at honey
love.com
toast make sure to use our exclusive
link to get that 20% off honey love h n
y l o
v.com toast after you purchase they will
ask you where you heard about honey love
please support the toast tell them we
sent you treat yourself to Honey Love
because you deserve it it's just so easy
to put on weddings business Tings things
of that nature a boost of confidence
Honey Love is truly the perfect plus one
so head to Honey love.com
toast thank you la yeah a well
our first story today's stories are very
Sports Super Bowl heavy because that's
what's news and the the Wags are in
Vegas not that that's even a story but
just like Super Bowl is in motion so no
for sure and I feel like actually we
haven't even spoken about it that much
given the fact that like it's here it's
imminent it's upon us it's Super Bowl
they've all been in Vegas for like days
it's Arab Super Bowl it's Arab Super
Bowl that's a cute
title it is arev means Eve in Hebrew
yeah so it's just like so You' say arav
Christmas know yeah exactly except not
in Hebrew
because why Jesus was a Jew yeah so
Jesus would say that it was a of
Christmas and you know the followers of
Jesus they with the Old Testament
so you actually might say AR of
Christmas you might I guess Jesus would
have said AR of my
birthday that's what he would say AR is
what Jesus would
say honestly I feel like we don't talk
enough hebra on this on the show but the
better tune
is it's just so basic I kind of love how
like do you think St wther ever recorded
that version maybe
yum
y I love when people dance as if there's
like an imaginary ball like you know oh
I never put I didn't know that that
that's how we were describing that's how
I'm that's how I'm trying to describe it
to you oh you mean this like yeah like
when they flip it up yeah that's called
the wo it's like whoa whoa who where'
that ball go there it is something like
that
y love that JY go
along whoa that's gonna look sick on the
p on the YouTube sick sick in a clip
maybe maybe anyways Arab Super Bowl the
new news is newsing let's start with the
big news of my day
yesterday something that really wowed
me I don't know Britney Mahomes oh yeah
in Sports
Illustrated Britney Mahomes Mama of two
made her Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
debut as a member of the rookie class
for 2024 rocking a series of all red
looks in honor of her husband Patrick
mahomes's Kansas City Chiefs and the
first photos were released on Friday so
photos were released plus a little
sizzle
real and damn Britney momes I was
shocked first of all mom of two with
that bod it ain't right it ain't right
it's so right and what's so oh it's so
right sorry I didn't mean I just no it's
so right that it ain't right right right
right right I I had so many thoughts
first of all the body was just like it
was insane to me like you know I just
was genuinely shocked by it also it made
me giggle because I feel like last week
it was in the news a lot this picture of
Patrick Mahomes viral he like has a dad
bod and he's like one of the greatest
athletes of our time and that's what's
funny about football is like they're not
these like perfect chiseled they're big
guys and a lot of them are a little
overweight too and they don't look like
what you would think a professional
athlete looks like so he was just in the
news and he made like a whole joke about
how his dad bod's actually like
underneath his belly pouch like it was
funny and his wife who's not an athlete
literally has one of the most insane
bodies I've ever seen in my life yeah
that is funny in light of Patrick but
Britney on her own I thought it was cute
which was in Sports Illustrated cuz she
is very of the moment and she's
obviously major in the Sports World and
so I was ready to you know look upon
these photos and I was just shocked
taken a back G were beautiful I also
like love the way that she was styled I
thought her poses were very modelesque
for just a a woman going about Glam Glam
she owned it I liked the looks I liked
the red I liked the entire thing I was
so surprised by how much I was into this
no I agree and like Sports Illustrated
is amazing and I feel like they do like
a lot of really iconic photo shoots but
at some point it feels a little
monotonous it's just like on a beach
blue ocean wet hair bikini like it's
kind of a formula at this point and it
works for them so for someone to like
look so different than the other photos
and really stand out like it was just
from top to bottom styling Glam
everything just gorgeous gorgeous this
is an absolute sleigh for her I saw
headlines like like responding to
backlash I don't even want to know what
the backlash is like I have haven't seen
anything and to me this is nothing but
totally positive agreed 1,00% I do love
though that like you know the the men
who buy these magazines are like the men
who are like pretty home sucks like
she's kind of like speaking their
language now and like in their magazine
and it definitely feels like a big you
know like fart in their face when people
are against Britney Mahomes she has a
lot of haters is it more men than women
yes yes yes interesting it's the
football people what and I feel like
we've talked but what is their beef the
beef started with the spraying of the
champagne from the men the men were
upset about spraying champagne well the
video had went viral and then it was
like oh look at her like she's in a
suite and it's really cold outside and
she's pouring cold water on people and
like it had come out people who were
there being like they asked they said
bretty spray us spray us like she did
literally nothing wrong but that's just
what offset people just being um put off
by some of her behaviors cuz she's very
supportive she's not like a quiet woman
you know this is her plate this is her
plate and and she's like really proud of
her husband and and her and I think she
definitely feels and I would too like
this is their success you know they've
been together since College they've been
on this journey together like he's able
to do what he does because she was you
know put her she was a college athlete
she put her things on the back burner
she started the family like they they're
a true partnership and so she takes
equal excitement and and support in in
their winnings it's it's if he wins the
Super Bowl they win the Super Bowl you
know you know love that yeah know it's
like a real family yeah and people just
don't like it haters going to hate no
and I just love love love haters GNA
hate hate hate hate
hate who's uh real housewi tagline is
that haters going to hate but I just
love love love Teresa yeah it's it's so
dumb it could only be Teresa it's so bad
like haters could cuz who is more
hateful than Teresa Judah is like ha is
going to hate but I just love love love
while I like physically assault people
like please factual no lies detected oh
we didn't talk about it and I didn't
choose it as a story but um people are
gagged over this photo of Jen Shaw and
Theos being spotted in
prison yeah people are gagged oh they're
gooped and
gagged I never watched any Theos content
like I know she like stole blood or
whatever but I st or stole did you say I
don't know cuz she kind of did both I
said stole she kind of did both I don't
really know her journey and like I don't
care to
um so like she doesn't do it for me she
doesn't do it for me I know her journey
I'm surprised these two get along I feel
like the commonality must be the fame
Factor because on a personality level I
feel like they would hate each other no
for sure like one is so serious so
serious like dead one is not dead she's
bloody serious she's bloody bloody
serious and
Jen not so serious right right but I
guess it must be like nice to have
someone in prison who can relate on a
very different but small level like why
you know Jen just can't talk to just any
end mate yeah and they can like team up
when the paparazzi come they could be
like you know we got each other I've got
someone to lean on about going through
this alone I did feel like it was crazy
to get like Paparazzi picks from prison
I feel like isn't prison of all places
supposed to be secure yeah and do they
just like wait all day or for for
recreational time or does Jen maybe she
uses her phone call to call the pap say
I'll be outside in the yard with Theos
come through 11:00
a.m. that's not a bad call if like share
is working with like a publicist and
finding her schedule that's not a bad
call she probably make money from that
yeah yeah yeah she probably sold the
photo like Yeah from inside love Yeah
from inside stops
hustling never stops hustling our next
story a bit of Super Bowl Eve ER of news
Travis Kelsey jokes about how much money
he's spending to have family friends at
Super Bowl
2024 so no one is immune to the pricey
cost of this Super Bowl not even the
players Travis said on the new heights
podcast I'm not really doing much
different other than just counting how
much money I'm spending on this damn
Super Bowl for family and friends to
come just making sure I'm on top of
those finances and losing all this money
it's really crazy I I can only imagine
how much he spent he's probably one of
the players spending the most amount of
money yeah the cost of the Super Bowl
and its VIP Suites has been a popular
topic over the last few weeks as family
members of players have been voicing how
expensive this year's game is going to
be uh now we attribute like all Super
Bowls are expensive they're always like
setting new records but this is
obviously different we attribute that to
tailored correct I personally attribute
it to Vegas cuz who doesn't want to go
to the Super Bowl in Vegas especially
for people in La like it's a 45 minute
there so much to do in Vegas it's it's a
very exciting place to have a Super Bowl
and it is a high-profile game but I
think even if it was debt versus Chiefs
or de versus
49ers it would be very much I don't
think it would be the same I think it
would still be extremely pricey maybe
like a little bit smaller but still
massive
yeah um so a lot is coming out about
Travis first of all the finances I feel
like he shared this cuz it's like funny
but also like he wanted people to know
like he's taking care of everything cuz
the question is like she's literally a
billionaire and he does extremely well
and I feel like this year's probably
made he made more money in brand deals
than he did from his football contract
and he has a great football contract
like this is a person who's deeply
wealthy and can afford it but his
girlfriend is probably 20 times
wealthier than him maybe more more cuz
his net worth is uh 30 million oh so
she's do the math for me how many times
uh 30 yeah 30 times richer than her my
guess wasn't bad 20 um so like you know
but then you know Traditional Queen
chivalry it's his game like there's so
many things so I really appreciate him
just kind of uh owning the fact like yes
I am paying for this well she's also she
has to get the jet she has to get the
jet but he also is responsible for his
family yeah so heend it anyway be paying
for them and so then it makes sense just
to like do a site and have Taylor not
pay but the sweets were going for how
much and2 and5 million that is wild and
for like a regular football game if you
wanted to rent a suite for like x amount
of people concert it's about 20
grand yeah so Millions is crazy it's
insane but also Alle legian Stadium
which is the brand new stadium in Vegas
is like this topof the line it has like
these crazy sweet it's like a nightclub
it's really one of like the coolest
stadiums in the country so it's already
going to have a premium because of that
and it's the Super Bowl it's like a
million things but $2 and a half million
dollar really crazy Olivia Copo just
made news because um her mother-in-law
Christian McCaffrey's mom went on a
podcast and was like we literally can't
afford a sweet Christian can't afford a
sweet even though Christian like has
like a $500 million contract whatever um
and then Olivia cop posted on Instagram
like don't worry Mom I got you yeah with
like a brand I think she got it was with
a brand so a lot of people missed that
cuz people are media illiterate and it's
really frustrating to like have
conversations with people cuz people are
like this is so insensitive Olivia
people can't pay their bills and it's
like it was literally a partnership
because she tagged this like agency
teasing some sort of thing to come so
like please shut up yeah it was
definitely gifted and now she can get
herself and Lisa in the suite also Donna
Kelsey had said she was probably
watching in the stands due to the prices
but I think everyone will be in a sweed
and and Travis will pick up the bill but
I think that's an investment in his
future no no and when I think about how
much money Travis Kelce has made
supplementary to his football salary in
the last year due to this Fame it's un I
mean the podcast just the podcast alone
just the podcast alone yeah they do one
episode a week they have like six ads
every week Millions it's it's number one
all week long like millions of downloads
and he's just splitting it with his
brother I know the numbers that's a lot
of money on its own face of Experian
face of State Farm he had that 60
million fiser contract he's fine stay
Farm did I say that yeah you said stay
Farm I think his fiser contract was $20
million how could it be 60 when he's
worth
30 I think it was yeah maybe 20 okay
whatever you know what I mean and I do
feel like his net worth is probably
needs to be rejiggered after this year
maybe but I also people are saying you
saber he triggered a lot to I didn't
feel that way though wa wait wait I kind
of do I kind of like that call but it
hasn't reached the summit yet for me no
it hasn't reached the summit but
definitely something I don't know if you
noticed today when I was making my
speech about the mouse I said it's not
representative of who I am I almost said
emblematic but I I came up with a new
word very good s thesaurus.com thank you
so much also this is weird Travis earns
about $14 million from the NFL so not
only did he get paid more for the fizer
ad which we know is 20 million I don't
even know how much he makes from other
ads but his NFL contract is around 14
million that feels kind of low
considering he's always get helping them
get to the Super Bowl yeah no I mean
it's not low because it's a part of a
bigger contract it's not like one $14
million I think he signed like a $50
million contract like three years ago I
don't know what's his what's his let me
look it up hold
on like what is his big ass contract I
love that this stuff is public like
that's so interesting to me like and by
the way when I just Googled it said his
net worth was 40 so it's already
changing changing by the he signed a
5year $50 million with sign with a $10
million signing bonus $20 million
guarant gued it's a good deal so for a
tight end by the way like he's not $50
million over five
years 10 million plus bonuses okay so he
makes 14 million probably in a year I
don't know he's using 114th of his pay
to spend on a suite that's not like
great financial it's not 114th of his
pay when you think about all of his
other revenue streams and fer 20 million
and he fiser State Farm Experian Subway
podcast okay but like I don't know pays
like fiser
pays I think they do I think fizer State
Farm Subway and
uh what was the other one I
saider Experian are all paying him at
least eight
figures okay but also the 14 million
from the NFL is in one year like those
ad campaigns is probably a year's Long
campaign you know some of them seem new
that's what I'm saying like I haven't
seen him being the face of Experian
before and it's like they tapped him
because he's hot right now or maybe he
like was like okay experience about $2
million campaign but I could use it to
pay for the suite right but he also just
buy that new house too million
yeah anyways that's another thing um
Hitler
ruined the number six million like o you
know I didn't even think of that I did
and it's like just add it to the list he
ruined the number nine of course nine
but he also ruined the number 6 million
like I I if I had a house that was worth
$6 million like I would put it at $599
because well you would anyway because
that's just better
business yeah I just I like I wouldn't I
would not put my house in the Six
Million it's crazy how PE like that's
still a business practice is to Mark
something at like19 instead of 200 like
that it's still and makes enough of a
difference people like aren't literate
you know makes enough of so like we're
still doing it yeah no it must be like
an actually effective marketing
technique that's patreon's only
$7.99 right and I just want to say like
patreon being $7.99 in this economy it's
free it's a steal what can you get for
under
$8 I don't know I just got a coffee this
morning and it was how much was
it oh she's too rich to
remember oh okay but I because I just
got the coffee damn I wish I clocked it
I was just excited to be out getting
coffee how exting homemade
free but in your plastic cup you just
want to kill the sea turtles no I needed
ice we don't have an ice machine at the
studio so from the coffee shop
downstairs I get a cup of
ice they must love me there I spend no
money and I come and take ice every
morning that's nice ice so well yes I am
killing multiple animals with my cup and
you know I should be murdered because of
it I do feel like I'm also like helping
by not contributing to consumerism you
know so it balances out okay but you're
kind of robbing a small
business it's not small let's say that
me you're kind of robbing a medium-sized
business I am stealing from a business
that I believe was invested in by Black
Rock okay I read that somewhere this big
chain of coffee shops in New York that
like popped up somebody said it's like a
black rock interesting yeah I feel good
about it thanks black Rock for my coffee
but I also saw that big chain like they
had to close a number of locations do
you think it was because of the ice that
you took maybe it's because Black Rock
was too busy buying like homes in
America every home in America what is
that by the way I fell into that
conspiracy theory black rock is buying
like and not like Mansions like regular
like single family homes that like were
normal and they're like gouging up the
prices or something yeah sick sick
sick and here I am with my with my
rental with my with mice Travis Kelsey
money he's paying for this this studio
what is it called the sweet um he's also
just making a lot of waves because he
has been like really and he's been such
a good sport about it but
like the way people have been acting
like sports journalists should seriously
like they should they need to be spoken
to some of the questions that he has
been asked and I've it's been coming
from female reporters and male reporters
like I can't even just blame one
particular group for being cring like
Travis finish the lyric yikes in like in
an official Super Bowl press conf like
did you see the reporter who asked Brock
pie if he saw this online the I don't
even know what you call online call that
he looks like Lee Harvey Oswald I did
this reporter like needs to get off of
Tik Tok like what kind of and Ro party
was like no I didn't see it he was like
what do you think about the comparison
he's like literally is a murderer no and
it's like oh I never heard that before
like great question thanks yeah no
people are acting like they they've
forgotten how to act and the questions
that uh Travis has had to field and he's
been really he hasn't made a stink about
a single one of them because he does I
feel like it's really intentional I
think he doesn't mind to think he's like
excited to be like you know popular but
also like he doesn't want to come off as
like I want to be known for me not
Taylor because that's like something
like a weak man would do yeah and I
think also when they've made the
decision to be so public and to go on
the field like you are saying okay this
is what a public relationship entails
it's not like he's been super private so
it opens the door for people to ask
questions which I think is fair yeah but
people have really taken yeah they have
taken they've crossed the line but also
the questions are dumb yeah like ask a
good question ask a good question oh
somebody asking me like who do you think
is going to get a ring first Taylor or
the
49ers could you die like I'm sorry
that's really insane yeah that's really
insane that was like that was like in
the beginning when they first started
going public and he was being asked
questions during a press conference
someone was like Travis are you in love
like okay we there's a line please like
sure ask your questions have fun with it
but like my God behave the state of
Journalism these reporters they need
they need to be spoken to spanked
spanked yeah they need to be reprimanded
deep playay what would you ask Travis if
you wanted to get like a tailored
question in
there oh wow you know what I would ask
if I wanted to get like Taylor music
question in there maybe I'm just as D
there the reporters but I'd be like are
there any Taylor songs that you listen
to to like psych yourself up for game
day by the way I love that and if he and
then I would also come with a list of
suggest questions ready for it get away
car like I would say if you don't like
here's what you should be listening to
on the bus right that's an excellent
question say hey Travis I made you a
playlist okay but also like obviously up
until this point I don't think Travis
was like listening to you know all of
Taylor's albums on repeat like as a fan
I just her Target he was in her Target
demo um now he's obviously like catching
up and stuff but like do you think he
knows a lot of her music no I think he
knows been two eras tours I think he
knows love sto
Shake It Off Blank Space 22 I knew you
were trouble and I think that's what he
should know I think now he goes to TS he
hears nice pretty music I don't think he
should look into it too much no I think
he will know Dead Poet
Society yeah like now moving forward I
always thought that was interesting when
um everyone was freaking out about
Kelsey ballerini and what's his name
Chase Stokes and all these this video
footage was coming out of him at
concerts like he almost immediately like
knew a lot of the words and people were
like that's so cute and it is really
cute but like how do you get there
unless he was a fan
before but at that point they had been
together for a while so it's like a lot
of going to her shows and hearing the
same song and he did go to a lot of
shows yeah that's okay I just I find
that interesting like how at what point
in a relationship with a singer do you
start to like memorize lyrics if you
didn't already and I also wonder about
being a singer do you listen to your own
music like say
you're pink like do you listen to your
own music at the gym like the rest of us
do
no you don't get to enjoy that song the
way that we do no no you sad what does
listen to when she's sad and as an
artist myself I can tell you I don't
listen or work out to my own music it's
really it's challenging I it sucks for
sure what I did find interesting and I
always think about when Taylor Swift
goes to an award ceremony and she's
always the first person to stand up and
dance during a performance she's like a
girly Who Knows lyrics yeah and I think
it's interesting I'm like be like did
she make playlists like and she like
knew vampire Olivia Rodrigo and she was
like mouthing the words and I'm like how
do you know the song no how does she
have all this time to make all this
music and listen to all this
music right and it's like when you make
music for a living like are you just get
home and you're like H I can't look at
another music you know yeah it's like us
being podcasters like we really don't
listen to podcasts no and I think like
Baristas like they get home and they're
like I can't make another cup of coffee
like you just like kind of expel what
you do for work yeah but I think music
some people believe in stop shut your
mouth I just think I told you that in
confidence I just think that the way
that some people believe in music Jack
I'm not about to say what you think I'm
going to say I think the way that some
people believe in music it's like bigger
than a cup of coffee yes yes yes but at
the end of the day like no matter what
you do for a living like work is work
even if you love it and have the best
job not for an artist not for a true
artist okay that's the point of the
artst tree oh you know I need to check
on Ben pain he didn't text me you need
to check on what Ben in the Exterminator
oh they're going out for coffee I hope
so like I want to be his favorite client
yeah like he comes over just to chat and
spray that's like people are like
teachers pet like no exterminator pet
like I'm going to bring you an apple you
don't want there to be a pet to talk
about
right okay are you ready for our next
story what number three oh God yeah
Prince Harry makes a surprise appearance
at the NFL honors after a quick trip to
see his cancer stricken father Prince
Harry made a surprise appear at the
annual NFL honors event last night
following his brief shift to London he
presented Cameron Hayward with the 2023
Walter Payton Man of the Year award the
highest honor of the night during the
ceremony in Las Vegas he said all you
guys do on and off the field is truly
remarkable you are role models for
millions in the way you carry yourselves
and in the way you gave you give back he
said that Hayward is a player who goes
above and beyond noted that his
extraordinary commitment to helping
others is a reflection of his own
story now I love um when Harry and Megan
decide to step out and like how he can
analyze what it means and so I don't
want to be ungrateful but like I don't
understand why Harry was at the NFL
honors football is not even a sport that
he is familiar with first of all it's
like the most American sport on the
planet two he just got back from London
oh and you know what I have fallen into
a Tik Tok rabbit hole that I'd like to
share now this begs the question did he
run home after 24 hours to to give this
award like oh my God good question not
that there was drama that Charles kicked
him out but he was like I'm sorry Father
I have a big American award to present
got a jet I'm sorry Father so there I
fell into a Tik Tok conspiracy theory um
like a lot of people think that he's on
his death ped King Charles like that
this is the end let I'm going to play
this Tik Tok for you and the person
actually made like a good person's name
is Adam okay Buckingham Palace does not
release statements about the health of
the royal family members until it 100%
absolutely has to Prince Harry does not
fly back to the UK to visit his family
unless he absolutely has too if you pay
proper attention to the royal family
it's never in what they say it's what
they do follow their actions if you want
the truth United Kingdom will be
coronating a new king this year what I
need you to understand in this moment is
that Buckingham Palace is currently
communicating to the public without
saying it there will be a new king this
year Buckingham Palace does not release
statement what do you think about that
time will tell like yeah sure maybe
maybe not
5050 it's so true
but if Harry ran home for this award
like loser energy that's now what I'm
thinking that he did I just want to say
like I think him being here is like
actually a bad look because there's
really no it's a mismatch anyway I think
in terms of like all the places he could
go like he would be better off at like a
film award like it it's not a match it's
not it's not American like it really
it's not a good match why would the NFL
honors have him anyway by the way the
NFL honors would have him because it's
just great press for their Awards like
that's fabulous but like it's the
biggest Award of the night there are so
many people in sports who are so like
respected yeah nobody in this room M
cares about him no no this room doesn't
care about him that's
true yeah it's a Miss for him I think
yeah it's a Miss for both parties but it
makes me wonder is he going to go to the
Super Bowl like we said he should right
cuz he is in Vegas oh and because he
clearly like knows about
football
but he's in Vegas they're going to the
Super Bowl dirty I mean NFL honors was
last night I didn't know that I wish I
knew I think I would have watched by the
way I literally had the same exact
reaction when I saw like news this
morning damn someone should told like
what channel is that on like ESPN I
didn't even Channel surf last night and
you know I feel like there was a a few
years ago where Kelly hosted the NFL
honors or it was the SS I get those two
Awards confused so similar and I think I
thought up until right now that last
night was like that the one no like yeah
no my husband he should have told me
yeah agreed 1,00% like that should be on
your radar yeah and when I was going out
to get a snack I should have seen it on
the living room television
yeah what and he wasn't watching that he
was watching some
drama I'm G to ask him about that I feel
like there should have been like more
commercials for it yeah maybe an add on
the toast and then we would have known
about it right maybe if ESPN had a
business that they cared about they
would know what it's like but they don't
but they don't so if anything else of
note happened at the NFL honors we
missed it yeah we did are you ready for
our next story that is brought to you by
tayor FMS Claudia we need to talk about
Taylor Farms the name on everybody's
lips Ben ate my last Taylor Farm salad
last night and I we actually got into a
fight Aros and Jena jail their chopped
salad kits deliver the freshest best
tasting salads to eat at home or on the
go across North America Taylor Farms is
a family-owned company on a mission to
create healthy lives through fresh
delicious food their chopped salad kits
AI boring in every bag with over 30
flavors each base is a unique blend of
greens veggies created to perfectly
complement the toppings and dressings to
deliver the best tasting flavor towards
salad kits I just want to say like
salads in a bag get a bad wrap and
rightfully so some of the stuff you pick
up at the grocery store Brown Taylor
Farms is different let me tell you why
perfectly packaged perfectly sealed
perfectly fresh but most importantly to
me perfectly chopped I love a salad
that's so teeny tiny shredded to
Perfection and Taylor Farms is always
doing the most with their chopping which
I feel like is the of utmost importance
and their flavors are so good obious say
I mostly stock up on the Caesar ones
because I'll like make chicken throw it
in or just use it as like a side for a
dinner party or something it's so good
the Citrus flavors they have such good
flavors it's such a good meal it's such
a good snack it's such a good thing to
just have in your house also if you're
having people over for dinner it's like
such an easy way to make a salad and
because all the ingredients come
prepackaged you can customize it like if
one day you want croutons and one day
you don't like you can just do what you
want you can do your thing yeah last
night I added some hearts of palm to my
Caesar kit yum yum purchase Taylor
Farm's chop salad kits where you like to
shop it's available at all major grocery
stores today's episode is also brought
to you by game time you should not have
to worry about when to buy your tickets
for your next big event game time is the
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer last minute deals all in
prices views from your seats and their
best pric guante game time takes the
guest workk out of buying tickets game
time is the only ticketing app that
gives you complete pece of mind with
your purchase see the view from your
seat before you buy so you know exactly
what to expect when you arrive the
all-in prices show your total up front
so you know that we're that you're
getting a great deal before you check
out buy tickets in seconds with two Taps
game time has deals on tickets right up
to the start of the event and even an
hour after it starts so it is the place
to find last minute ticket deals find
exclusive Flash Deals and sponsor deals
on tickets for football baseball
basketball concerts comedy theater and
more with Zone deals you'll be able to
pick the section and Game Time picks the
seats for big time Time Savings and with
the game time guarantee that means
you'll always get the best price so if
you find tickets in the same section in
row for Less game time will credit you
110% of the difference so take the
guesswork out of buying tickets with
Game Time download the game time app
it's just just a great app to always
have on your phone whether you're live
in a fabulous City where things are
always going on or you travel a lot for
work it's just a good thing to like you
know help you stay in the know create an
account use code toast and you'll get
$20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
toast t o a s for $20 off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guadan guadan our next story
little game news actually I think all
five stories have a bit of a sports
theme which I think is great as it's is
er of Super Bowl it is er Super Bowl um
Cascade will replace Testo at the Super
Bowl as the big game's first ever
official DJ so we had spoken about how
Testo was supposed to be the DJ for the
Super Bowl which is so Vegas and so
Testo and like during the game question
mark I think we were me we were going to
see you know I'm sure he would be doing
it for the fans but I'm sure there would
be some TV component and he was the
Super Bowl DJ how fun is that yeah okay
but he had to step back due to a family
emergency he said me and my team have
been preparing something truly special
for months but a personal family
emergency is forcing me to return home
Sunday morning it was a tough decision
to miss the game but family always comes
first thank you to the NFL etc etc well
the good thing is like you know they're
in you can't fart without hitting three
DJs and big ones too so Cascade great
huge that's great hope everything's okay
with Testo yeah same for me Cascade will
be great I do now I'm like wait what did
Tiesto have planned sound exciting no
now I'm like intrigued like what the
does being the DJ of that Super
Bowl entail that's what I'm curious
about I think it's it would have been
really cool and now I'm like or is it a
job that's just like in name only you
know not for I don't think Testo takes
iname only jobs my my question is is it
a job that's for in stadium only do the
people at home get to enjoy it yeah
there there are a lot of things about
the Super Bowl Jackie and I have been
that are really we were there made
they're they're either made for TV or
made for the stadium the superable
halftime show like when we went it was
Justin Timberlake right yeah we didn't
even hear him like it was so it wasn't
playing on the screens it's truly made
for TV like nobody is watching it like a
concert it's not like that at all um and
that was disappointing for sure yeah cuz
like you would say like let's say Taylor
was going to the Super Bowl and be like
okay I'm going to go to a Taylor Swift
concert you're literally not the
microphone's like not even on no and it
depends which way they're facing but
they doy 360 but I just felt like
everything was happening on the other
side for Justin Timberlake like selfie
kid wasn't sitting near us we had
totally like back view of Justin
Timberlake and I couldn't have been more
thrilled about it him yeah um like
of all the performers we had to miss
like I would have been okay with that
totally fine but I wonder if the Super
Bowl DJ is like an inst Stadium thing
because also then you deal with like
music licensing on TV it's like a whole
thing but they have every they play
music all day long yeah we'll see I
think it's going to be really exciting I
think Cascade will rise to the challenge
but I am bummed like now I'm like what
did TS do have plann and does Cascade
have enough time to plan something of a
similar elk TS is like really
major yes tury like when you just think
about like Global artists like who could
sell out stadiums in like Germany like
we always think like Taylor Luke Morgan
Wallen literally like these DJs are so
crazy Rich Glo like globally it's insane
yeah like those Tomorrowland audiences
are hundreds of thousands of people yeah
it's just interesting it's like such a
subculture that we're so not tuned into
not even
sub right it's just a culture yeah
massive Massie
blockv exactly our fifth and final story
is a little halftime news because Usher
is giving the whole show is the whole
show Usher's giving some teasers about
his halftime show saying it would be
foolish to perform at the Super Bowl
show without inviting Lil John and
ludicrous on stage because he said it
would be foolish not to perform his show
song yeah also ludicrous and Lil John or
wait what's the song yeah I get confused
with the Chris Brown
one How does it
go let me just play I'm just being a
grandma right now I feel like there's
like four songs named yeah yeah I
agree oh oh yeah yeah Jackie copyright
turn it off turn it off I put it away
from my microphone and closer to you
yeah you keep doing that where you think
like you'll do something away from your
microphone it was the one time and
obviously I didn't push my mic I do that
all the time I move my microphone and I
sneeze over here and it's always fine I
think the one time that I was blowing my
nose during Quinn sorry to the squins I
didn't move the microphone far enough
Jackie let's talk about you blowing your
nose during the Quin ad um how many
people texted me like what's going on
like literally a bomb was going off
first of all I'm sorry I should have
moved my microphone or muted it I'm
really sorry the point number two I'm so
glad you guys don't skip through the ads
so true ra parcel was like what's going
on ra parcel listens to our ads like
that is a we're influencing the
influencers I think every once in a
while we need to do something crazy
during the ads just to make sure people
are still here okay on Monday I'll like
rip ass during T Farms or something I it
didn't need to be as soon as Monday I
would say like every maybe like
quarterly an ad check in oh okay so not
tomorrow no no no not tomorrow I just
did my crazy Quin blow the
CQB yeah okay wait really quickly back
to Usher I feel like it's very rare for
a Super Bowl performer to ever confirm
prior to the show like who he's bringing
out but I also feel like it means he's
bringing out everyone if he's if he's
teasing these two I think Justin
Bieber's coming I kind of agree and I I
kind of feel like I normally would have
said oh I wish he like shared it didn't
didn't I wish he waited to share and
like surprised us all but like kind of
now feeling like knowing what's coming
in the anticipation I'm actually more
excited like I feel like it actually is
going to be a 10 out of 10 performance I
think it's going to be just a
celebration a craion as Friday episodes
are here at the show but I
also sometimes when someone's performing
the whole time I'm like I'm waiting for
this song are they going to bring some
out like it's the anticipation you can't
enjoy it so much I feel like that
happened with Rihanna everyone's like
ooh it's all of the lights is Kanye you
know and if if we know a little bit okay
people are coming great we're not so
like worried about suspenseful that's
actually so true it kind of takes away
from the performance cuz you're just
then you're going to end up like always
feeling let down yeah unless but for
Rihanna I wanted her to not bring anyone
out I think it would have taken away
from her to bring someone out I don't
feel that way about Usher because I just
I feel like his song's like the more the
marrier sort of thing no and with Usher
like so much of his career and his
success are built on collaborations
whereas Rihanna's that's really not the
case no but so many of her hits are are
collabs actually yeah but like but just
coincidentally yeah like no I can't
explain it I no no I agree with you on a
metaphysical level but on a literal
level it's not the case it's different
it's just different I agree yeah you
know it doesn't require explanation I'm
so excited for the Super Bowl this
weekend for the halftime performer for
the pre-show performance for the game
for the tailor you know Kim Kardashian's
probably going to be there cuz like
skims is like doing a thing with Usher
like there's just a lot that's going to
be going on and I feel like I'm it's
just going to be a great week weekend to
be on my phone yes but also off your
phone because we're going to be together
so it's a little bit of on off it's a
little bit of on off and what's so
exciting is that the show is far from
over well not far from over that's like
kind of dramatic yeah that is but we
still have more there's more we still
have more our weenie of the week and our
Queenie of the week crowning has
officially commenced our weekly segment
where Jackie and I just take a look back
at the week at a glance and give out two
Awards one to the Queenie of the week
and one to the weenie of the week two
people who exhibited either Queeny like
values or weeny like values 100% how do
you want to start let's start with
Queenie like get the good one out of the
way my Queenie of the week is Miley
Cyrus for me Miley she won the Grammys
in a literal sense but her energy she
shined so bright no I love she she was a
inspiring I've spent the week listening
to her music just entering into another
Miley appreciation ERA this is one of
many in my lifetime and she is just my
absolute Queen I hope she had the best
week of her life and Queenie Vibes only
from her I love that mine is also
Grammys related different but it is
Tracy Chapman Queen because you know
what I've been seeing on Tik Tok like
this her performance has just gone so
viral and of course like the luk of it
all it brings me so much joy I love like
Luke getting his flowers from people who
aren't in country but Tracy Chapman is
just this like deep ly talented deeply
nonthymic and I just I loved it and
Tracy Chapman is responsible for it love
love now I do think the weenie of the
week there's only
one oh okay who's yours it's I know that
it's yours too I don't think so Annie
Lennox oh I scratched mine yes my weenie
of the week was going to be us for how
we've been acting with the 5K like we've
been like really weeny and we need to
stop we're so but the thing is we're so
cute I know and like the clips are going
viral so honestly I take it back and
like we're like I know it's you say
we're desperate and thirsty I think
we're really
Earnest like we just we just want to be
involved and meet new people and
included and exercise meet new people
support support small podcasts get
outside get some fresh air support some
men who could really use a leg up I love
that by the way you're 100% right and my
God yes Annie Lennox is the weenie of
the week I don't know how I missed that
Annie Lennox sorry not Annie Lennox is
the weenie of the week Annie Lennox is
the weenie of the
week I hate ha Annie Lennox and once
again thank you for reminding me of my
new life's Mission which is to make fun
of Annie Lennox whenever possible every
chance we get which weenie of the week
is that and Howard Stern actually did a
segment similar to weenie of the week on
his show about Annie letics and I loved
it so thank you Howard for championing
my cause facts were spoken how about
artists for the release of releas of the
hostages say that first yeah then let's
talk peace no everyone wants peace what
are we animals no but saying ceasefire
to a group of Barbarians who have said
time after time we don't want to stop
being barbarians we want to kill Jews so
saying ceasefire is just saying the
Civilized people the Jews isra need to
cease fire and stop defending themselves
shut the up you dumb ugly and
then die right because the other side
will not cease firing and they've made
that known time and time again so if you
are confused why ceasefire is trash
that's why
artists for ceasefire sounds like
artists who are deaf because they're not
listening no and it's like okay artists
for what about the hostages in that
situation so we cease fire and then the
hundred women teenagers men like
grandparents who are just sitting there
what about them and they're not just
sitting there they're being abused on
every being raped emotionally physically
verbally assaulted please shut the
up and shut the up and you should I
would say shut the up and sing but
like don't even do that like no cuz you
weren't good at that either no I'm sorry
I didn't mean shut the up I meant
shut the the
up it's like it's like a big yawn yeah
and honestly I don't even remember like
how she actually sounded because I've
dramatized it so much in my head and
it's funnier in my head for sure love so
that's Queenie and weenie of the week
truly turning into one of the highlights
of my week I'm so glad we started doing
that yeah um and that is our show so
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
us on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe give us video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast by the
way anywhere podcast can be found so
it's Spotify iTunes s public radio I
Radio cast box all the places wherever
you listen to podcast find us the toast
leave a five star review about have
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are without further Ado we bid you a
do love you
bye